if you're attending PAX East in Boston
this year come join the gamespot crew as
we host two super fun panels in the
bumblebee theater on saturday April
twelfth at one-thirty p.m. will be
recording a special PAX East episode of
the lobby complete with awesome guest
school games and sweet prizes then at
nine p.m. on saturday come on by for the
chance to beat game developers at their
own games and are demolished the
developers main event flex your skills
in hearthstone ultra street fighter 4
and titanfall and claim a glorious
victory that will echo throughout the
ages there will also be privacy if you
can't make it to pack see you can still
watch all the excitement and shenanigans
on gamespot com will be streaming the
demolished the developers replay on
Monday April 14th at 11am Pacific and
again at two p.m. the lobby will be
broadcast at its normal time of 2 p.m.
pacific on tuesday april fifteenth and
whether or not you're going to pax east
if you live in the boston area we want
to hang out join us and our friends from
giantbomb.com at the atlantic beer
garden on friday april eleventh at 8pm
it's only a few blocks from the
convention center so come on by and have
a few pints with your favorite people
who talk about games for a living hope
to see you there
Oh